but you you've met moshus parents
correct of course I mean they're married
I would hope so why can't I just ask my
baby write a questions right I'm feeling
a little a lot of people listening right
now they don't [ __ ] know that is so
funny to go to Beyonce and then just
start acting like an [ __ ] came home a
just dropped my suitcase yeah open it
what did she do that made you feel so
empowered I honestly could not believe
that this woman had just birth twins and
she put on a two-hour performance and I
part of it is that she just had a baby
is that what everyone heard of it is
just how much she put out there cuz I
saw a lot of performers over the weekend
and no one even came close to the amount
of work that that woman done she always
does that right oh wait yeah I mean
energy you can tell she enjoys it and
she really wants to leave it all out
there like she just she doesn't phone it
in she's doing it all out did she sing
halo she did write like migos is like
wasted song halo yes that her song oh
yeah I bet you don't like Beyonce I like
Hale always hailer I know why you don't
like Beyonce though because she's black
if you say no I went crazy out here I'm
gonna say something worse
why cuz you have really good taste in
music do we not do we not though you and
I are good taste in music you can't
really like Beyonce I love that you said
that and that's why I love you so much
saying I mean I know she's a very
powerful empowering woman but you can't
say well I'm sure it speaks to people
but can I diff can I defend it by saying
this though I don't know if you know
this about me but in the last three or
four years what is it just say it what
is it okay can I just get my last point
out then howdy
okay but anyway but here's the thing is
I've been obsessed with talent shows and
singing shows I'm obsessed with the
voice I'm obsessed with America's Got
Talent I'm obsessed with x-factor all
that [ __ ] okay you should be a judge on
the gong show what's the that's what is
that
it's a talent show don't you remember
the gun embarrasses the show no well
there's a new gamma shell yeah to remake
with that Mike Myers as the host what
Mike Myers is doing the gong show pose
talent show and then you could be one of
the judges yeah but you know Comedy
Central is it I don't know how far he
dropped no heat this guy was the biggest
[ __ ] comedy movie star and now he's
[ __ ] a [ __ ] game show host wait so
tell me about what talk about him
congratulations Mike to get on the show
for getting the gong show now you're
never gonna be on the gong show
and I hope Mike listen I really do
he won't is I just I thought I really do
believe that he's the Peter Sellers of
our generation I love Peter so he's the
best I know he's the best Peters there's
rarely a talent out there like that
someone that really just embodies a
character and you're convinced you know
and I think Mike Meyers has that kind of
talent he's one of the best that's why
I'm saying it it's not if he was just if
you I'm gonna if you said Dean cook is
hosting the gong show I'd be like Oh
congratulations
that's great for him he's a great comic
I love him
yeah but he's not Mike minors is what
basically worm so I was giving him props
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I agree what's the [ __ ] ad
[Music]